how you doing people it is january 12
2022. i'm dave florida rubin reporting
to you live from florida the greatest
state in this once great nation it's
going to be great again i've got a
little work to do but we're going to do
it and of course we are on youtube
rumble and blaze tv do me a favor share
subscribe tap the notification bell all
that stuff i consider it a solid much
appreciated uh we are doing a q a today
and ask me anything we got dozens and
dozens of questions at
reubenreport.locals.com which if you
have not joined you should so that you
can play along and ask me anything
but before we get to that i wanted to
talk to you about yesterday's state of
the state right here in the great state
of florida because i mentioned on the
show yesterday that ron desantis
governor ron desantis was doing his
state of the state union uh state of the
state address and in many ways it really
is the country's state of the union we
all know the state of the union right
that's when the president comes out once
a year in january tells you what he
thinks about the world his vision going
forward what they're going to do what
they want to do who the bad guys are all
that stuff
well frankly
i don't think joe biden is very good at
his job and i don't have any faith in
the democratic party at the moment and i
don't think there's a real vision there
although maybe there is and it's just
not a vision i like
let's put that aside for a moment but i
do think what's going on here in florida
is pretty freaking fantastic and i know
i have a bunch of questions about it in
the q a that i'll get to in a moment
well ron desantis gave his state of the
state and i wanted to
show you a couple clips from it and i
will leave it up to you to decide for
yourself whether you think the vision
that this guy florida man ron desantis
is putting forth is a vision of a
country and a state that you would want
to live in that protects your rights
cares about you as the individual
doesn't believe that it is designed to
govern over you forever or if you think
joe biden's better and we'll juxtapose
some desantis and biden clips you know i
love the word juxtaposed but first i
want to talk to you guys about alto you
know cryptocurrency may represent the
future of money it's one of the most
exciting investment opportunities to
come around for some time but what about
taxes with an alto crypto ira you can
trade crypto like bitcoin and avoid or
defer the taxes with alto you can create
an account in just a few minutes no
setup charges involved you'll experience
secure trading 24 7 through alto's
integration with coinbase you can choose
from 80 plus coins available including
bitcoin ethereum and cardano and also
allows you multiple ways to fund your
account make a cash contribution
transfer cash from an existing ira or
roll over an old 401k ready to take your
investments to the next level diversify
like the pros and trade without the tax
headache open an alto crypto ira with as
little as 10 bucks just go to alto ira
dot com reuben that's a l t o i r a dot
com slash reuben start investing in
cryptocurrency today go to alto
ira.com
reuben and now back to me all right
let's get right to it desantis gave what
i think was a pretty spectacular state
of the state address but don't take my
word for it here's ron in florida we
have protected the right of our citizens
to earn a living provided our businesses
with the ability to prosper
fought back against unconstitutional
federal mandates and ensured our kids
have the opportunity to thrive
florida has become the escape hatch for
those chafing under authoritarian
arbitrary and seemingly never-ending
mandates and restrictions
even today across the nation
we see students denied an education
due to reckless politically motivated
school closures
workers denied employment due to
heavy-handed mandates
and americans denied freedoms due to a
coercive biomedical apparatus
these unprecedented policies have been
as ineffective as they have been
destructive
they are grounded more in blind
adherence to falcian declarations than
they are in the constitutional
traditions that are the foundation of
free nations
florida is a free state
[Applause]
[Music]
god that's absolutely beautiful i'm
living in bizarro california my whole
life has turned around he talks about
things like the constitution remember
that we used to think we used to think
that the constitution was pretty great
he talks about kids having the
opportunity to thrive he talks about the
mandates and why they're bad all that
stuff
but i know i want to give the devil as
due
joe biden must have a plan for america
so we said okay let's put together a
little uh compilation of some of joe's
thoughts
because we cannot get re-elect we cannot
win this re-election
excuse me we can only re-elect donald
trump
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time well for their trust
and confidence
got a lot of thanks to give out here
first and foremost to my perfect wife
stephanie
and the kids used to come up and reach
into the pool and rub my leg down so it
was straight and then watch the hair
come back up again
they'd look at it so i learned about
roaches i learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap i
learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap and i love kids
jumping on my lap so you can see there's
a contrast let's say of styles right
but
maybe that wasn't enough to really prove
the point here's more from ron desantis
we reject the biomedical security state
that curtails liberty
ruins livelihoods and divides our
society and we will protect the rights
of individuals to live their lives free
from the yolk of restrictions
and mandates
florida has stood strong
as the rock of freedom and is upon this
rock that we must build florida's future
[Applause]
all right pretty good people in florida
are gonna live their lives we're gonna
have this rock of freedom sounds good
but again i don't want to dismiss joe
biden out of hand
let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree hey by the way
where are you in oregon
and you fell off sideways you landed on
the damn the darn cement over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
number two
but look fat look here's the deal
here's the deal
no you haven't you're a lion dog-faced
pony soldier you said you were but
you're
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids we hold these truths
to be self-evident
all men and women created by the
you know the thing
you know the thing
all right i don't want to be
heavy-handed though so i'm not even
going to say any more about this you
guys just take all of that and think
about how you want to go forward with
your life what type of person would you
want
governing someone like you
desantis or court but
you decide uh guys before we get to the
q a let me talk about expressvpn real
quick when did we decide to stop
upholding free speech as a basic right
it's been a while what's playing out
right now at big tech companies and
social media sites sets a dangerous
precedent look it doesn't matter what
your politics are or who you voted for
everyone should have the right to
express themselves freely sadly the big
tech monopoly has instead opted for
silencing tactics and censorship to
fight back i recommend using expressvpn
ever wondered how tech giants make their
money well by tracking your searches
video history and everything you click
on by building a profile on you and then
selling off your sensitive data when you
use the expressvpn app on your computer
or phone you anonymize much of your
online presence by hiding your ip
address that makes your activity more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cyber criminals but
what's best is how easy it is to use it
takes just one click to protect all your
devices that's why expressvpn is rated
number one by business insider so let's
stop allowing big tech to revoke our
rights to free speech why not revoke
their right to your data instead secure
your internet with the vpn i trust for
online protection visit expressvpn.com
ruben that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn.com ruben to get three
extra months free with my exclusive link
go to expressvpn.comruben
right now to learn more and now back to
me all right let's dive right into the q
a thank you guys
uh for submitting so many questions we
tried to mix it up here we go darren
says what has been the biggest surprise
in your move to florida
well look the easy answer
is that you know i'm free that's not
really a surprise i think the surprise
has been just
how stark the difference
between living in florida and living in
california like people here are out and
about
they're smiling you see their faces
they're engaging with each other like i
feel like i've talked to more strangers
and had more just sort of pleasant
interactions with waitresses and
bartenders and just people on the street
and everyone that's coming up to me is
friendly you know usually i do depend on
the kind of strangers and people are
usually very nice to me uh you know
people that know me um when they come up
and say hi you know whatever they like
the show but like there's something
different about the way that people are
when they come up to you here like there
is a reason for being here and i've gone
to a couple parties that did not involve
social distancing and all of the people
that i'm meeting there are there's such
an influx of refugees and i know there's
always that worry
there's always that worry okay are these
people gonna bring those bad voting
habits are they gonna just do all the
things that they did
in those other states in those blue
states but i really sense that people
get what they're fleeing like the
difference right now between florida and
california the difference right now
between texas and new york these things
are so the gap is so wide that people
get it so
your question is about the biggest
surprise it's like even though i knew it
was going to be different i cannot
believe how different it is i genuinely
feel like i'm living in a different
country and maybe that's just how it was
supposed to be and that means that the
whole experiment is working so that we
can have a state of the state by a guy
like ron desantis and i know that the
machine here is set up to free us to
keep us free
and it just ain't that way in california
so the surprise has just been really
it's just been every day here has been
wonderful so far really it's just been
great uh craig says do you think that
ron desantis serves the country better
as the governor of florida or as a
presidential candidate in 2022 if not
desantis in 2024 who would you support
so everyone's asking this question uh
you know i mentioned that i had this
dinner with desantis a couple nights ago
and it was off the record and there was
some conversation around that which
he didn't really comment on and if he
did i wouldn't be able to say it anyway
um my personal preference at the moment
would be that he stays the governor
of florida like the state that you live
in is just going to be more important in
some ways than the federal government
going forward yes the federal government
can declare war across the world the
federal government is supposed to
protect the borders the federal
government has a couple other things
it's supposed to do we have these
bloated budgets and ridiculous uh
departments you know department of
education et cetera et cetera but it's
very obvious that the state you live in
is more important right now so i would
love to see you know desantis is just
still in the midst of his first term i
would love to see him stay here
keep strengthening that bedrock of
freedom that he was talking about
earlier right like keep making sure this
thing is set up right so that the other
states that care about freedom can model
it for themselves i think he's also
showing people that you can relentlessly
and mercilessly stand up against
mainstream media because the hidden
pieces on this guy are just nuts like
they're pulling the trump stuff with him
and he's either ignoring it or punching
back even harder which is great so i my
preference at the moment would be that
he keeps florida florida and then we
figure out what to do in 2024 as far as
who they should choose if not desantis
well look let's sort of put trump aside
for a moment he either will run or he
won't and if he does he's going to be
the candidate so that's just like one
piece of this thing but i would say that
first off i honestly i still do not
believe that joe biden aka corn pop
is going to make it all the way to 2024
his cognitive functions just ain't right
everyone knows this thing is not working
his approval rating is tanking like the
thing is not working if you think joe
biden right now only one year into this
disaster like if you think he's not
great now how do you think he's going to
be in three years from now and then
having to come having to campaign and
everything else so then the que the
obvious question is well then do they
run kamala
nobody really likes her like what do
they do now people are talking about
hillary again but i know you're asking
me about the republicans my point is
that i think they're going to be so
damaged
at that point
that the republicans will have a lot of
opportunities so i don't know exactly
who it is like i could go for a guy like
tim scott let's say uh you know there's
obviously nikki haley like there's a
there is a crop
of people right like there is a crop of
people ted cruz rand paul i mean he'd be
too libertarian for sort of mainstream
but like there is some version of
something that can work uh i just want
to see the states flourish at the moment
so that that would be my preference but
i don't i don't i honestly don't have
any insight into his real thinking on it
desantis that is uh joe says who would
you like to have as a guest but haven't
had on the show yet you know people ask
me this a lot i always say that bill
maher is sort of the the main one at the
moment because i do want to discuss sort
of what happens at the end of liberalism
and that he gets it on the free speech
stuff as you know he gets it on wokeness
and critical race theory but at the end
if you're going to still tell people to
vote for democrats and you still believe
that high taxes are good and you still
believe in the welfare state and all
that it's like what do you really
believe so i do want to discuss that
with him i've been somewhat critical of
bill but i do like him i think that
i think that he could really help usher
in what would be this new wide tent on
the right and i would love to talk about
that obviously i want to have ron
desantis on we're going to do that one
for sure no doubt um i'd really love to
have george lucas you know i don't talk
about star wars that much it's really
been all banged up i didn't think boba
fett was that great i didn't love
mandalore and everything else but i
would just love to talk to this guy who
created such a world that so captured my
imagination and captured the imagination
of several generations of people and i
would love to talk to him about what it
was like to fight when he was like an
indie filmmaker sort of making star wars
fighting the system then ultimately
selling the franchise to the corporation
and then watching the corporation disney
and then watching the corporation sort
of destroy his art and what that
struggle is like there's just a ton to
talk about there so how about that bill
maher ron desantis george lucas oh and
then i'll do one on the tech side of
course elon musk who you know basically
if we're going to continue on earth like
this guy's got the right ideas and
meanwhile elizabeth warren is always
trying to attack the guy it's like has
she ever produced anything other than
pretending to be a fake indian so she
could get a job so elon musk would be a
good one too
emily says how do you feel about the
government limiting limiting monoclonal
antibodies and the media downplaying
their effectiveness i'm in georgia and
it's almost impossible to figure out
where to get it i think they have blood
on their hands for limiting people's
ability to get this potentially
life-saving medicine so i on the latter
part of that i completely agree the fact
that the media
and state governments have been so
heavy-handed in not telling you
other ways to
take care of yourself rather than the
vaccine or in addition to the vaccine
the fact that when job
rogan took ivermectin the media went
crazy for a week saying he was taking
horse paste and it's like yeah there is
a version of ivermectin that's for
horses there's also a version that's
been prescribed to humans for decades i
think at this point i took ivermectin it
was three pills i took them for three
days i think and and i felt better i
also got monoclonal treatment here in
florida which was extremely easy to get
and i was basically better in three or
four days i had some leg aches some
headache whatever
but in florida sorry in california for
example you have to come to them with
the positive cova tests to then get on a
line to maybe get monoclonal treatment
it sounds like they're doing something
like that in georgia it's actually you
know on one hand it feels it's like
crazy like how does this make any sense
on the other hand it really does make
sense
the governments
especially in these blue states and the
cdc and the nih and everything they want
to control every bit of your life they
want you to get vaccinated i'm not even
convinced at this point that they want
you to get vaccinated because it's going
to keep you healthy right we know that
the vaccines really aren't working as
promised but they want they're sort of
testing can we just get people to do
whatever we want when we want them to do
it and can we get them not to use their
own logic and reason and can we get
doctors to not abide by their
hippocratic oath can we do can we push
these people so far and then guess what
in a year from now they'll push us again
and then they'll say ah there's the
climate we've got to worry for climate
change we better lock you down again
don't drive your car
so
these people are criminals as i said
yesterday i'm not one for throwing
people in the gulag that's what they
they do but what are we going to do with
these people who have lied about
everything
who have made
crazy profits the the drug companies
pharmaceutical companies the politicians
who have just absolutely shredded the
constitution everything else what are we
going to do i don't know exactly what
we're going to do but i would say
relative to covid you should have access
to whatever medications you and your
doctor think are going to work for you
and then you should take into account as
much information as possible and figure
out what's right for you and if you
don't live in a state that will let you
do that there are some other states out
there uh giannis says will you do any
meetups in miami i would love to meet
you and hang out with members of this
community yes absolutely for sure you
know we've been here for a couple weeks
now we're finally closing on the house
this week then we'll get into the
temporary studio next week and i'll be
back at 11 a.m our new time 11 a.m
eastern live going forward starting next
week uh and then we're going to build
out our full studio so we'll have a
temporary studio in the house then the
full studio uh i mention all that
because i just haven't had a moment
we're in boca right now shooting at
newsmax there's been a million things
you know we got covered so i wanted to
get here and just do a hangout
immediately we were just gonna you know
do a reuben report uh locals community
hangout somewhere in miami it's just
been kind of nutty since we've been here
so i got to get settled in the house for
a week or two
and then i think we'll try to do a
locals meet up and then i want to just
do like a big miami event and then of
course my next book don't burn this
country comes out in april and i'm only
going to tour
in venues and in states that do not have
mask mandates and
don't force you to show
a vaccine id so if that keeps me only in
florida and tennessee and texas then so
be it i was talking to my guys maybe we
can figure out a way to do like uh well
they're gonna be pissed that i'm saying
this out loud but like seriously
discounted tickets for people that come
out of state because it's going to cost
you to come into the state to come to
the show but we'll figure it all out
landon says any updates coming to locals
and rumble in the near future yeah
there's a lot going on so as you guys
know
locals and rumble have merged so locals
is the official subscription partner of
rumble rumble which is not just a
youtube competitor but really an amazon
aws the underbelly of the internet
competitor we've got a lot of stuff
cooking i don't know what they would
want me to say exactly so i can't say
much but i will tell you this we
genuinely are doing it we are building
the parallel ecosystem right big tech is
not going to fix itself and the
government ain't going to fix big tech
and i don't even know that it's the
government's job to do it so what did we
all decide all of the people that i've
been working with on this you know first
by creating locals then talking to the
rumble guys why we decided to come
together
we did it because we believe that you
can just build a better product build a
better product and if you build it they
will come somebody said that once in a
movie and uh so we're working on an
entirely parallel ecosystem so
ultimately you will not be
reliant on youtube on google on facebook
on meta
and all of the other such nonsense so i
hope to have a little bit more on that
for you guys soon
mary says dave at the rate their vaccine
narrative is falling apart these days
how long until you see it turning our
way we will be on the right side of
history truth always prevails so i do
believe that truth always prevails i
really do i believe that truth is so
fundamental to the human experience that
we yearn for truth we get lost in the
[ __ ] but we yearn for truth that the
the liars and the the con men and the
people who want to control you they
can't control us for that long that's
the human story right like the
individual will always triumph but it
can be freaking messy along the way uh
your question really like how much
longer till the narrative completely
collapses i mean this is like this is a
tough one because it's like more and
more people are waking up there's no
doubt and you can see the machine morph
right in front of us right suddenly
things that everyone that we were all
saying two years ago about you know
mandates seem you know like maybe that's
not really constitutional or wait a
minute these masks don't work and how
does it make sense that when you walk
into a restaurant you have to wear a
mask but when you sit you don't like all
of the nonsense that they've pushed on
us you can now see some of it reaching
mainstream so suddenly they'll say
things like that on cnn and that's how
sort of evil the machine is they'll call
us a bunch of racist backwards you know
conspiracy theorists when we said the
right stuff two years ago and then they
start saying it now as if they've been
saying it all along and the reason they
do that is because they're seeing the
narrative shift i think what really
caused the narrative to shift more than
anything else is that over christmas
and really into the beginning of the
year and a little bit right now where
omicron was really running rampant and i
knew easily 20 people if not more who
had it all at the same time some were
back some weren't but everyone basically
had the same results everyone survived
some people were a little sicker some
people weren't as sick whatever it is
some people were sick and didn't even
get tested right some people tested and
they weren't that sick all of the stuff
i think what happened is it forced
people in their own mind when you see
what happens right in front of you you
go oh i got i got four friends two of
them were backs two of them are in facts
they're all roughly the same age and
everybody survived and
then you start thinking you go well then
wait a minute why did everyone have to
get the vaccine why did governments
force companies to fire people why are
we getting rid of nurses who don't want
to do it if at the end of the day if you
get the vaccine you're still going to
transmit it don't boot me youtube you're
still going to catch it don't boot me
youtube etc etc so i think truth
and reality is like forging a way
through and we just got to keep pushing
because the machine
the machine is always one step ahead for
some reason
shannon says would you ever come to
phoenix arizona to do a meet and greet
of any kind i still have hope that my
home state hasn't gone blue the way they
say it has even with all of the
californians moving here if not i'm
happy to make a special trip to florida
anyway i truly couldn't be happier for
you and david with your big move can't
wait to see the new studio and what this
year brings for you well thank you for
the kind words i'd love to get to
arizona
phoenix in particular i did a stop in
phoenix with uh with jordan a couple of
years ago i did a stand-up in tempe
i don't mind that dry heat but i would
love to see see you make move over here
over here in florida i sense arizona is
going to be okay you know they had a lot
of stuff around the election that people
weren't happy with i think that's
energized a certain amount of the base
obviously blake masters who's my buddy
is running for senator in arizona i
think he's getting some nice momentum i
was actually at a fundraiser that he did
here in miami a week or two ago and he's
good and he's honest and he's decent and
he doesn't even really want to be a
politician which is exactly why he
should be a politician in a way so i i
have hope for arizona i don't know the
specifics of like what's going on in
phoenix exactly but i think i think
arizona actually is gonna be okay uh tk
says how many alligators have you seen
so far
none in person believe it or not so i'm
doing the uh the miami area thing and
we're up in boca right now uh i know
more alligator places on the southwest
side of florida which i haven't made it
to yet i do love the southwest area oh
and i may do an event in southwest
florida in february we're working on
we're working on something there uh
relative to the previous question so i
haven't seen any alligators yet but i
like alligators as you may remember i
had two
huge alligator uh pictures uh they were
like six foot uh photographs of
alligators in my old studio which now
have even a deeper meaning to me i've
always enjoyed the reptile i've seen a
lot of iguanas we've seen some huge
iguanas how big was that iguana we saw
the other day i would say
three feet we saw a three foot iguana on
a dock the other day that's pretty good
that's sort of like a mini alligator but
i do look forward to seeing and feeding
some alligators actually there was a
mini golf place
that i used to go to with my folks down
in southwest florida where they have
alligators just in a moat in the middle
of the mini golf thing and you can feed
them you put like some food on a little
almost like a makeshift
fishing pole kind and you feed the
alligators pretty great okay
storm says will you work with people who
enforce vaccine mandates
no to the best of my ability the answer
to that is no i mentioned before i'm not
going to tour in places where there are
mass mandates or vaccine mandates i just
simply will not do it i don't care how
much money it costs me i know the
publisher is not going to be happy with
me i'm just not doing it i can't write a
book about freedom
and about these things and then say oh
but i will perform at places where
they're going to force you to do it
because
like i just can't do it i can't do it so
will i work with people who enforce
vaccine manage my goal would be no hey
look i own and operate and control my
whole business i am my boss um so
you know there could be some other
i don't know every vendor we work with
so that's the best way to say it like i
don't know every single vendor we work
with i don't know every single uh
company exactly that we work with in
every single policy but i promise you
that i will do my best not to work with
companies that force things and you know
that force these things on
their workers um and of course you know
this can be very very tricky you know
we have a lot of operations here like
there's the show
there's the production company there's
the book there's touring like all of
these things
but this is what the parallel economy is
all about so to bring it back to that
question about locals in rumble it's
like those of us that believe in freedom
we need to start exercising that freedom
we need to say it's not just that
there's a problem and woe is me there's
a problem we got to damn well do
something about it and and build better
things whether that means we have to
build our own airlines and build our own
new tech and have build new restaurants
and everything else it's like
what do you have better to do than save
the world i have nothing better to do
amy says have you discovered any new
favorite things in florida that you
could not get in california other than
freedom and if so what are they
man has there discovered any new things
that i couldn't get well i couldn't get
ivermectin in florida and i couldn't get
a monoclonal treatment in florida which
i had both of those
but you want something more fun than
that um
let's see well this is very exciting
i got i went into a store i'm in boca
right now by the hotel i see this great
clothing store and i was like you know i
want to get some new fresh clothes for
the show a couple jackets couple shirts
etc etc i go into the store start
chatting with the owner it's like a
local mom and pop top mom and pop type
operation uh tony who might be watching
this i know your wife's watching it i
start chatting with tony turns out that
his wife is a big fan
i think maybe i'm going to speak at a
local group that she has here
but just going into a store and chatting
with someone and not wearing a mask and
i was like i want to spend freaking
money here and i bought a lot of stuff
you're going to see a lot of new jackets
i'm wearing shoes for the first time in
a long time i usually wear boots
and i'm happy to do it i was like yes
this is what it's all about a good man
who wants to own a store
and and you know sell great products and
i i wanted to spend money there i really
did so that's what it's all about that
really is what it's all about we've gone
out to dinner people just start talking
to you we're sat at the bar people
talking to you
so i guess that's all couched in freedom
but it's just it's just been great it's
just been great i've died and gone to
florida uh rebecca says what's your
litmus test for good conservative
candidates if you have two questions to
ask them to get to their core
what would those be
um
you know i try not to do the litmus test
things so specifically i i like a little
bit more just sort of a holistic like
you can get a sense
of what people believe if you let them
talk enough which is usually why i enjoy
interviewing people the way that i do i
feel like if you if you give people some
rope uh you know either they're gonna do
something good with it or they'll slowly
hang themselves so i try not to do so
specifically like here are these two
things that you have to believe look
individual rights is the number one
thing it is the
bedrock idea of western society that
individuals have god-given rights you
are born free as a human being the
government did not make you free joe
biden did not make you free it is an
innate
human right
that you will have
the as we've written in our good
documents
the potential for the pursuit of
happiness because you have god-given
rights in the government protects those
rights did not give them so you have to
believe in individual rights i would say
is number one and then for a good
conservative candidate
well i would say this because i think
this is the big issue right now which is
you i think you have to really think
through
when government power should be used i
think one of the reasons that
conservatives fail
is that conservatives generally because
they so believe in individual rights
because they believe actually in choice
not because they just say they believe
in choice which is what the lefties do
because they don't want the government
to do that much i think conservatives
often are like ah let's just the
government shouldn't do anything because
we're conservatives and we believe in
small government and the government
should do anything that's more of sort
of a libertarian approach and that's why
i don't consider myself a libertarian
a pure libertarian
i like libertarian ideas obviously and i
like
you know like the intellectual exercise
of how much we could do with no
government and all of that stuff but i
think one of the things that
conservatives have to grapple with right
now is what are we going to do in the
face of wokeness and critical race
theory as they infect our schools and
what are we going to do
as
people move from blue states to red
states potentially the people with bad
ideas should you have to take some sort
of a test to move into a new state i
mean i think we have to honestly think
about some pretty complex stuff related
to when
government has a right to use power
because otherwise you're not a
conservative because if a conservative
is trying to conserve something conserve
freedom in essence conserve liberty
conserve family and and our ability to
pass on that incredible tradition of
freedom from generation to generation so
you have to honestly think about that
stuff and i think conservatives often
get lost in that and we probably all
have to do a little bit of a better job
sherry says are you nervous at all about
the hurricane season in florida um
honestly no not really i'm not living
right on miami beach which obviously you
know gets gets hit pretty hard once a
year or so but you do get the big
hurricanes here every now and again but
look i lived in california in los
angeles where fire would just rain down
from the sky once or twice a year
you may all remember when we had those
crazy wildfires in florida about two and
a half years ago where there were those
pictures of just cars driving down the
405 and just i mean it looked like
complete
you know just absolute chaos of just
fire everywhere and people put scary
music to it and and all that stuff it
looked like mustafar which was the
lava planet in star wars um
that was right by my house by the way
one of the fires they called it the
square ball fire it was about a mile
away from my house so
you you know things happen things happen
um you do you do the best you can uh we
had the inspectors come to the house and
you know the house is pretty solid
we're going to make a few changes
related to hurricane windows and that
kind of thing but i'm not i'm not that
worried if there's a massive hurricane
to come in
uh you know maybe we go up north for a
little bit but florida's been here for a
long time it's going to be all right
ethan says with the left going down this
path of lunacy more and more each day do
you find it harder to keep the title of
classical liberal or do you feel as if
you should start going by a new title
just like how you abandoned looney
california for sane florida you know i
talk about this
a bit look i wrote a book
defending the ideas of classical
liberalism
i think in a sane world i would still
consider myself a liberal by that
definition
the word liberal has been destroyed
there are
very few actual liberals left
certainly that consider themselves
democrats are part of the left the left
has become monolithic and authoritarian
show me a democrat politician who
doesn't want to control every part of
your life who has policies that make
sense that allow you to decide things
over your your life i mean give me a
democrat really think like is that what
nancy pelosi wants or aoc or chuck
schumer or joe biden think of any
democrat right now when is the last time
you heard a democrat give a speech and
talk about freedom or choice or any of
those things that ron desantis talked
about at the top of the show today they
don't talk about those things they talk
about how we can do stuff for you right
if you just allow us or allow that's
kind of a funny word if we just take
enough of your money we can figure out
what to do it so you'll all live a
better life by the way we're going to
get real rich in the midst of that and
we're going to live a whole other life
that you're not going to be allowed to
live because we're not going to do [ __ ]
with masks and we're going to vacation
wherever the hell we want but you you
peons shouldn't do that so the
democratic party has been destroyed this
is not the democratic party of john f
kennedy jr
right like it's just not that anymore so
um
to say i'm a liberal it's like it
doesn't really make sense anymore
i would say i'm a bit on the liberal
side of a new conservative movement i
like that i also like you know there was
i think for many years
a lot of young people particularly
particularly
didn't like the phrase conservative it
sounds old and stodgy and i think there
was an association with like you know
people smoking a cigar and like stuffy
rooms talking about you know the dow
jones and money and war and all sorts of
stuff and it's like that probably had
was true at some level or you know like
it was just sort of a cliche or a meme
or something but now first off when i'm
around conservatives conservatives are
nicer conservatives are happier
conservatives agree to disagree
conservatives more generous of time and
spirit um and
so
i like calling myself a conservative at
this point i really do
it's it's been an odd shift for me and
that isn't to say that i don't believe
any of the things that i laid out in the
first book because i still do believe
those things but those things have been
abandoned by the liberals and
i can't i can't disconnect liberals from
liberalism there's a problem there by
the way that's something that i would
love to discuss with bill maher uh all
right bill says is aoc related to the
spanish conquistador cortez reparations
anyone i don't know but i would say yes
aoc owes us all reparations that that
absolute
infuriating vaccine mandate ho i can't
stand her she's just terrible and it's
not because i want to have sex with her
and it's not because i care about her
boyfriend's feet it's because she's a
horrible human being these are bad
people i'm sorry it just is what it is
right like i you guys know
i'll be sarcastic on this show i'll i'll
be jokey and silly and all that stuff
but what what is there left to say about
someone like aoc who does not vote
in the house anymore
personally because of covet right she
actually signed a document so that
someone else votes for her because cobit
is so scary yet she will go down to
miami that is free while demonizing ron
desantis for the last two years she'll
go down to miami go to a drag queen bar
have all the gays oh my god it's ayo
i can't believe it they're all living in
a frog my god
and she's hanging out with these people
and she's laughing and she's day
drinking and everything else they don't
believe their own [ __ ] so aoc you're
just a bad person i i it's like that's
an odd way to talk about politics but
that's what she is that's what she is
eric swalwell vacationing down here
you're a bad person whitmer vacationing
down here you're a bad person
these people i want that i want nothing
to do with them and that's why i live in
the free state of florida
that's all for our q a today uh i've got
a quick interview about a 15-minute hit
with senator rand paul coming out a
little bit late is it a little bit later
today
it'll be out it's out right now you can
find it on youtube and on rumble and of
course you can play along at
reubenreport.locals.com
we've got two more days here at the
newsmax studios in boca raton
and then
assuming everything goes well move into
the house in the next day or two we
build out temporary studio over the
weekend and we are live at our new time
11 a.m eastern
starting on monday
i'm psyched i'm ready i'm i'm just happy
to be here i'm happy to be back i thank
you guys for all the kind words that
you've been sending along have a great
day everybody
and i'll see you tomorrow
you